I and this is always a sensitive subject
so I caveat it with for people to listen
to what I'm saying and kind of leave the
emotion at the door but Jason and I were
talking about it just like when you have
bad data whether you make a good
analysis or a bad analysis of that data
you end up making bad decisions because
the data was bad and what I mean by bad
day together is we have no what pretty
high accuracy how many people have died
right for the most part yes there are
some questions about somebody could have
died it could have been labeled or you
know mislabeled or whatever but for the
most part we know the people who have
died from the virus and kind of their
immune response etc what we don't know
and pretty much everyone admits is we
have no clue how many people actually
have the virus or have been vetted and
that the data points that just blow me
away or you know they tested like two
NBA teams and nine people on the team on
the different teams had kovat 19 and
they're out there playing NBA games you
know the night before two days before
one out of the nine I think showed
symptoms and so you get into this thing
where there's actually probably a lot of
people who have they're asymptomatic and
kind of walking around and maybe they
thought they had the flu or they don't
show any symptoms ever yeah and so when
you don't understand what the accuracy
of the denominator is we just can't make
good decisions because we don't have the
testing in place to actually understand
how you know what is that mortality rate
how bad is this and then we go and we
make you know obviously very kind of
bold decisions whether they're good
decisions or not we just don't know
because we don't have good data to look
at now it's such an important point and
and look we know the data is bad right
there's no question that data is bad we
didn't have enough tests we weren't even
aware of the virus in its presence in
the US for for probably four or five
weeks it was probably here and we just
didn't even think about it so we know
the day is bad and to your point we the
death data is is absolutely easy to
ascertain right there's a death
certificate there's a body now what we
are learning it is possible in some
cases where there's comorbidity right
someone has lung failure or heart
failure and then they get the virus
where they're in the hospital and if
they code that as a corona virus death
is it really
so that's one of the things that they're
talking about in Italy because if you
look at Europe at Europe is really the
epicenter of the virus in addition to
China and if you look around Europe one
of these things doesn't look like the
others right Germany almost no deaths
like 194 Switzerland one of the highest
per capita infection rates very low
number of deaths the Nordic countries
Sweden's Norway and Denmark very low
number deaths so it's only Spain and
Italy where you have this this very high
mortality rate er or case fatality rate
that just seems odd the data just seems
inconsistent so to your point if you
have bad data you're going to react to
things and you're gonna make potentially
bad decisions it's kinda like we're
talking about in investing right if if
you had access to good information early
you could make a good decision well what
if you had access to bad information
what if somebody fed you bad information
you'd make a bad decision or what if you
synthesize the data wrong you you missed
something in your your exclusion you
make a bad decision or what if your
model had a mistake there's the famous
story of of you know one of the most
successful real estate investors in
history very stern like you know he was
kicked out of JM be real estate in
Chicago because they blamed him because
they said he took down the firm because
he had a mistake in his spreadsheet
because none of the other partners knew
what a spreadsheet was back then
I'm not old right and the crazy thing
was Barry might have had a mistake in
the spreadsheet but that's not why they
went down they went down because they
had too much leverage on real estate
into the financial crisis in the 90s so
it wasn't Barry and Barry turned out to
be a really smart real estate investor
and billionaire now so he's done okay
but the other thing that's interesting
to your point is some of the decisions
were making our decisions without
knowledge and I'll use just one example
so school closures sounds like a great
idea oh it's brilliant
oh let's think about this for a second
we know one thing about this virus its
impact on age
population is much much worse the case
fatality rate for over 70 much much
higher than under 70 and in fact under
65 the recovery rate is like 99.9
something so it's not a hundred but it's
pretty close so and in the lower cases
there's very few incidents under ten
almost no incidences under ten very
strange but that's what it is so if we
left schools open those people who are
young healthy and resistant to the virus
could have kept the virus amongst
themselves by closing schools
particularly colleges and sending those
people home to be with their parents or
my age in their late 50s or their
grandparents who what what if and I'm
not saying that necessarily happened but
it's a higher likelihood of spreading
the infection to the vulnerable
population and when we think about
actions we have to think about reactions
and the closure of all activity seems
like a really bad idea
the protection of vulnerable populations
like my parents are in their 80s I am
really worried about them being exposed
because this virus is very harmful in
fact to personalize it a little bit one
of my very good friends his wife lost
both parents in the last two days took
Ovid 19 tragedy I mean absolute tragedy
you just can't even comprehend it so I'm
very worried about this and I'm doing
everything I can to protect that
vulnerable population even to the point
of excluding my contact with them my
kids contact with them their
grandchildren we're not going to let it
happen so I think thinking through the
process rather than just reacting to the
process probably makes a little more
sense